it goes a lot deeper than simply rich
people in government who don't give a
[__]
there is a problem of our Economic
Institutions our intellectually bankrupt
and I I that sounds extreme but listen
I've got a degree from LLC I've got a
degree from Oxford I've worked I've been
in think tax I've been in the city I've
been in economics for
18 years now in many different spaces
my honest opinion is that economics is
intellectually bankrupt as a discipline
I've got a question on Twitter
the other week very simple question why
don't governments tax the rich
um
and I think that's a really interesting
question and it's actually
I think to think about it and to answer
is quite interesting so so before I
start I should say you know I'm I'm not
politician I don't know many politicians
very closely okay so we kind of make
some assumptions about what they're
working with but you know I often say
when I'm asked this question I say well
extremely extremely well you know I
can't emphasize how wealthy is
unbelievably richer than me unbelievably
which then probably anybody watching um
his father was one of the richest men in
the world
he's super super super super super super
rich right so this is the guy in charge
of
making the decision should be tax the
rich so he's probably not going to make
it right and then the chance that Jeremy
Hunt I think he's worth something like I
don't know 10 15 million pounds also
very very wealthy man again much much
richer than me
um
he's probably unlikely to do it right
before that Boris Johnson he's going to
make millions of pounds he already has
probably since leaving office David
Cameron made 10 million pounds from
Green cell you know within a year of
leaving office right so and Tony Blair
he must be worth what I don't know 50
million 100 million these guys are super
rich right so
if the people you put in charge
are very rich or about to become very
rich you can see there's a pretty
obvious conflict of interest there in
dealing with policies such as should we
tax the rich or the very rich more
because they're basically deciding the
policies that will apply to them to
themselves right so I think that that
definitely
plays A Part
but I think that there is actually
something
deeper going on which is which is
important and we should discuss that
um because
within a couple of years we will
probably have a labor government in this
country
um
and again you know you could point the
same charge at the labor leadership you
could say these the labor leadership is
not as rich as a conservative leadership
and their donors are not as rich as a
conservative donors but they still are
very many relatively wealthy people in
that party and when they leave office
you know Tony Blair for example became
very rich so you know we could point the
same thing at them but
there's lots of countries in the world
and there's lots of governments and we
have some governments which are sort of
left-leaning and in general they haven't
implemented big attacks on the rich
so that raises the question
about why
and I think
what is happening is that
politicians themselves generally
are not economists and they're very
rarely
expert economists
so
political parties they tend to basically
go and ask economists you know what
should we do what should we do and
I think the truth is at the moment if
you were to ask
most sort of average run-of-the-mill
economists you know not Traders people
who've gone to work in civil service or
in government or in think tanks
um what do you think we should do
tax the rich more is still a relatively
Niche opinion right Within
economics
and we have to address the question
about
basically why that is why is that and I
think
to understand that you have to
understand what is happening in the
universities basically economics
so
economics as it is taught nowadays are
most of the most prestigious
universities
is a extremely mathematical subject very
very very very mathematical
um you if you want to do well in it and
we're talking about macroeconomics here
so we're talking about the economies of
countries if you want to do well in it
realistically
the main thing that you have to be able
to do is to memorize algebra so from
2017 to 2019 I did a two-year economics
Master at Oxford
um the first year of that course we did
a macroeconomics module the exam was
three hours and the first two hours is
basically just the regurgitation of
memorized algebra that's basically all
it is
um and then the last one I was essay
questions but everybody knows that
everybody gets the same score if they
ask their questions anyway so really
when these kids go into these university
courses
they are they are hard the first thing
I'll say is they are hard so sometimes I
maybe give an impression that economists
are
stupid but the truth is to get an
economics degree is difficult you need
to memorize a lot of algebra and you
need to have some kind of understanding
of the algebra and how it works how to
manipulate it right it's not easy
but imagine you you have gone into an
economics degree you've got a big exam
coming up you've got a ton of algebra to
memorize
you are going to spend all of your time
memorizing algebra right
so what what these guys get is they get
given models which
the theoretical complexity is not
actually that much they're not
particularly complex in terms of theory
in terms of ideas but they're very
complex in terms of algebra and I think
by the time you've come through sort of
you've got your Masters you've got your
PhD you will have spent you know nearly
a decade
doing very very very very very
complicated algebra
about pretty theoretically simplistic
ideas
and by the end of that
you become
you've spent so long working on the
algebra and so little thinking about the
ideas that you start to completely
subconsciously completely accept the
ideas it's almost like a religious
indoctrination
because you've had to spend so long
memorizing the details
and you've you've never had any time to
think about the concepts that you've
never you've never actually stopped and
thought is there something missing from
these models and one crucial feature of
these models
is that the vast vast majority of the
models which these people spend their
time looking at
contain no inequality they contain no
distribution
they are what we call Representative
agent models so they look at
the total of the economy the aggregate
or the average
and of course when you look at the whole
economy
total
you're not looking at the distribution
there is no distribution so these guys
have spent years and years and years and
years
slaving over the intense memorization of
algebraically complicated models that
have no inequality and no distribution
and by the end of that
their whole life their whole skill set
their whole career is predicated on the
the unbelievably intense memorization of
these models with no inequality in them
see what I'm saying
so they are
they are unbelievably attached to these
models with no inequality in them
and everything you throw at them they
will instinctively think of in terms of
these models with no inequality in them
it's it's it's like an indoctrination
because you've studied for years and
years and years and years and years
memorized and memorize exams and exams
tinkering tinkering algebra algebra
never any inequality in any of the
models right so it's deeply embedded
into them not to think in the economy in
terms of inequality and in terms of
distribution that's like it's like baked
into their veins and also
if inequality were to be important
that would essentially mean that they
[__] wasted 10 years of their life
and hundreds of thousands of pounds
right so they cannot believe that
inequality is important they cannot and
I think
the the great example of this I've used
it a couple of times before is when I
asked the professor at University at
Oxford why do you think people spent so
little money after 2008 and he said
we're not sure but we think it's because
of an exogenous shock shock to
consumption savings preferences
what that is a technical modeling term
meaning meaning this particular
parameter on people's brains change and
they stop spending money
it's totally nonsense to use that as an
explanation for the real world but he's
so inculcated he's so deeply bread into
his blood these models he cannot think
about the world in any way other than
through these models and it's important
to understand that this is the training
that all economists get and with regards
to Traders you can be a Trader with an
undergrad but if you want to be really
influential influential in policy
or in government then you need to get
PhD basically so these guys are in
three-year undergrad one or two year
Masters another four or five years PhD
so they've been really really they've
really worked these models for a long
time right it's really a massive part of
who they are so they
simply do not ever think of the world in
terms of inequality
and that explains why amazing things
happen
like
the government gives 700 billion pounds
out and no one asks who gets it
because if you don't care about
inequality you don't care who gets it
you know somebody got it but you don't
get who because you just think you're
thinking about the total right you're
not worried about distribution you're
not worried about inequality and
this leads to
this leads to exactly
the kind of thing that I mentioned in
the video about Jeremy Hunter and black
swans
because if there was a structural
worsening problem of inequality in the
economy and you had been trained for 10
years to never look at inequality
what you would see is
everything's fine but we keep getting
better at bad outcomes
it's exactly like if you had cancer but
you went to a doctor who didn't believe
in the existence of cancer
he'd be like there's nothing wrong with
you but bad things keep happening to you
you're just unlucky just keep waiting
keep eating healthy keep exercising
and you're going to be fine
this is the world that we're in it comes
from
the state of economics which is
economics is taught to people with no
mention of inequality and no
understanding inequality and then you
add this extra layer on top of it which
is if you are able
to come to the understanding that
inequality is deeply important in our
economy and it's destroying our economy
you can go and work in a skyscraper over
there and make two million pounds a year
so once you understand that this is the
system that we've made we've developed a
system which intensely trains economists
to ignore inequality
and then massively rewards anyone who
understands the importance of inequality
under the condition that they leave the
public sphere and don't speak publicly
it becomes basically obvious that we
won't fix this problem right
I mean
how much money have I personally
forfeited
to leave that job and do this channel it
will be 10 million pounds
how many people are going to be willing
to do that not many people right
so
it is basically inevitable that all of
the economics information that goes to
the government that comes out on the
news that goes to all the new people is
substandard almost all of it because if
it wasn't substandard why are they
telling you why are they telling you why
are they giving up millions of pounds to
tell you
you know what I'm saying
so then
I think the end result is that
in government you get a set of people
who what is really happening
is a a combination of stupidity and
greed
which is these economists are not well
trained to understand the problem but
they're [__] well paid to do whatever
the [__] they're doing
Jeremy Hunt Boris Johnson these guys
will make a fortune you know these guys
make a ton of money it doesn't matter if
they fix the problem and the economists
who advise them okay they're not going
to be multi-multi-millionaires they're
going to make hundreds of thousands of
pounds a year they're going to be
comfortable it doesn't matter if their
advice is wrong and anyone who does
understand can get paid a ton of money
over there so I think
really what is really happening is the
system is is quite rotten at the core in
in a way that is itself a manifestation
of inequality which is that
why would the general public get good
economists
when the rich are going to pay good
economies two million pounds a year to
work for them
you see what I'm saying it's it's not
inequality doesn't just mean you don't
get a house it also means the government
cannot afford good the best people in
many cases when you add on to that a
terrible education system with economics
and a massive outside incentive for
anyone good to leave
it becomes inevitable but I think the
key thing that is missing
is that
even not paying that much
the government could attract people like
me if it was able to identify good
economists
but
I think it's relevant that someone like
me can walk into Citibank and be famous
within two years
whereas I can try and give the
information away for free on the
internet and okay we're growing now
we're growing now but I'm nowhere near
as famous as I was at Citibank and that
is because the public sphere media
government is very very bad at
identifying good people
you know we've got a video about June
2020 saying there's going to be a mass
increase in inequality house prices
stock prices inflation collapse and
quality of living you know what I mean
that we should be famous on that right
because that's an amazingly good
prediction from the Stars massively good
evidence from somebody with a massive
track record of good predictions it's
massively good evidence that I
understand this crisis better
than the guys in government
but the problem is government is not
designed
to go and get good people and make them
on the country nor is the media
you know the problem is these
institutions that are supposed to run
the country
the people who are in them
are not incentivized to do good
economics the people in government are
trying to win elections
in many cases they're almost trying to
rob you because they literally are the
super rich
the people in the media are just trying
to make professional looking TV shows
they don't give a [__] with their
analysis is good or bad right
they don't put me on there because they
know I look unprofessional it's as
simple as that yeah they don't give okay
do they give a [__] that my analysis is
actually right who gives a [__] nobody
nobody in TV cares about right analysis
all they want is it to look good right
so the problem is you know
all of these institutions
they're not incentivized to find good
people and to do good things in most
cases they're just big bureaucracies
with their own incentivizations and
everyone is trying to build their own
careers you know
so
it goes a lot deeper than simply rich
people in government who don't give a
[__] there is a problem of our Economic
Institutions our intellectually bankrupt
and I I that sounds extreme but listen
I've got a degree from LSC I've got a
degree from Oxford I've worked I've been
in think tanks I've been in the city
I've been in economics for
18 years now in many different spaces
my honest opinion is that economics is
intellectually bankrupt as a discipline
that most of what they do is a complete
waste of time most of these guys it
would be better off if we just sent them
out of the country and started again
because they are absolutely tied to a
set of models that have no distribution
in them keep predicting things will get
better things keep getting worse and
they will never figure it out they will
never figure it out because it is in
their blood to not consider the
distribution
add to that they're getting [__] paid
for it they're not the guys getting hurt
I always remember when I was at Oxford
in my mid-year review in this [__]
castle and these guys saying you know
what do you think of the course and I'm
saying [__] and they're saying well what
do you mean I said you're not talking
about anything that's [__] happening
I'm talking about economic the economy
is in a disaster and they said to me
what do you mean the economy's getting
better
but for these guys it [__] is and for
these guys the economy has been getting
better for 20 years and they will be
saying the same thing in 20 years when
the country's flooded in poverty because
for them it will get better for them it
will get better so I think
it it has to be it has to come from the
people it has to come from the people it
has to come from a burning desire and
unflinching demand do something about
the wealth distribution or we will never
vote for you or we will never accept it
we will we will fight you until you give
us that thing it has to come from that
because the economists are not going to
do it for us it has to come from the
people and if we get enough popular
demand then we can start to challenge
the economists but it has to come from
the people because the economists are
[__] paid they are [__] paid
they're [__] bought and sold and they
don't give a [__]
and that is why
the government doesn't tax rich people
so we have to make them do it we have to
make them do it
housing could be so much more affordable
wages could be so much higher and we
could have so many more options in how
we live our lives some of them put a lot
of money into paying economists and
think thanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not
true
[Music]